what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
before i start do not forget to
subscribe
you know throw a like on this video
today
i am going to be reacting to the fit and
fresh podcast
labeled the guy she banged probably
banged her as well
[Music]
oh my gosh is it fresh and fit i've been
saying fit and fresh
i i got a question for you this one will
be an easy one ladies just out of
curiosity and we'll start with miss
matthew over here
what percentage of men do you think are
sexually active with women
percent yeah percent of men
it's like 20 right
i think 50. 50 okay okay what about you
miss california
that is sexually active with women yeah
yeah 85
okay okay and miss buddy um
wait do you know the answer to this yeah
she does okay i mean
in relationship single single
in a relationship zero men are just not
getting anything
sometimes so what do you what do you uh
she knows right
yeah i know yeah yeah okay then okay all
right then
okay i just want to reveal to you guys
the answer is
only about ten to twenty percent of men
are having sex with about eighty to
ninety percent of the girls look at her
face she's like
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you know that really hot
guy
you did he probably did you too
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah man if you're a really heavy
sleeper you better watch out he might
have come
done me too i'm a lifesaver because
but no for real like a very small
percentage of men are having sex with
all the girls think about it
women want guys that are over six feet
tall make a certain amount of money
whatever
that's a very small percentage of men
that meet all these requirements yep so
all the girls are chasing the top ten
percent of men
yep so what he does is at the club you
remember the married guy
with them right oh i'm gonna salt in
that wound
okay so the mr married guy was he tall
was it good looking yeah okay yeah right
well he
he had you and he had his wife and then
the next weekend after that
he might have somebody like you and his
wife and the weekend after that
he might have someone like that
and so what's happening is is women say
i want the best men
and so she'll go home with him on a
weekend but he won't date her
he doesn't want a girlfriend yeah do you
know why
yes yes i don't know do me what do men
like
women right yeah so why would he settle
for just one when he has so many that
want him
so what happens is these top 10 15 20 of
men
have a hundred percent of the women that
want to sleep with him
so what he does is he goes to the club
and you're like oh he's hot and he's
this he's a great guy and he's
whatever and so i'm not saying you would
generally do this but a woman will be
with him
and then the next and he hits it and
quits it and maybe the next night or the
next weekend he's with another woman and
another
and and what happens over time is all
these men are just working their way
through all the women
and then the women go but if i sleep
with him and i treat him really special
he'll choose me and i will win
and you don't and women keep going on
that carousel
wait what we have a word for that
carousel dome
yeah i would
i definitely like witnessed this in
college
yes we do what could it be what could it
be
is it the penis carousel no that doesn't
sound like and we literally call it the
[ __ ]
carousel and the reason why is because
women will all get on that ride and ride
the same
ones over and over and over again and
that guy never stops he never settles
never and
in the meantime 80 of the men the ones
that would actually
and i'm giving you this for a few you're
how old i'm 22
future advice you're not ready to settle
down yet you got to wait to your prime
years
you know 40 to 45.
[Laughter]
so what happens is women keep thinking
i'm going to sleep with this great guy
and he'll choose me for a girlfriend but
it doesn't work
but here's another great guy and another
and another and the guy's never settled
but the eighty percent of the
hard-working dedicated men
that would really actually love and
support and be with you
they're invisible women don't see them
and so when you think uh 50 of men are
active
you're probably thinking of 50 of the
top 20
can you do you go to a gas station fuel
station
i can't even add anything to this this
is straight facts like
the more i've listened to like
manosphere space the more
like stuff kind of clicks regular one
to go to a store is there a place you go
buy sandwiches on a regular basis like
is there a store
you frequently visit is there a man that
works in there
why not i mean do you know of one
i'm not sure like cvs or like walgreens
like any place that you go on a regular
basis can you
yeah cbs for example yeah yeah but can
can you think of anybody that works
there
can you be interesting what half the
people that work on cbs are like 16.
like because they're invisible to you
yeah oh oh oh
okay okay that's what he's trying to say
yeah
you follow what i'm saying okay yeah
like like like you s like what are you
saying is that like
you see the men yeah but they're not
even like an option for you
yeah you know like so you don't look at
him and say i wonder if he's dating
somebody or
maybe he's a a guy that would like today
like he doesn't register to you
okay like he doesn't it's like the guys
in your dms the one in the top ones
you're going to respond to the rest
you're never going to look at right
they're invisible like but like men it's
different like you see a girl
like you're like is she hot oh she is
okay cool i could do this
and then if you're drunk enough she's
always hot you know what i'm saying so
it's like men
look at it completely different like
women don't even like there's a lot
large percentage of men that are just
invisible to you yeah you're not going
to notice if they're not even if they
don't meet your height requirement right
all you ladies i think said what you
said five eight five nine
six feet the most reasonable really yeah
like that i think this is the first time
someone wasn't like
uh five ten yeah yeah five ten normally
five
seven eight three four right yeah six
and three on stuff but ladies
that's like the older you get you stop
stop caring about all the superficial
stuff
in my opinion although right so what is
a turn off for you so for example i know
most guys
like they've talked to you in public
probably you're polishing your dm
but like what turns you off completely
like you know what no i'm not even gonna
give him a chance
so what turns you off oh
i'm gonna answer this question um
completely
i shouldn't be as hard to think of
something it's been a while since i've
been dating someone
or like in the dating game so to speak
i would say
back in the day it would be like
not having the same like
political and like religious beliefs
like in person no he wasn't he was
asking me no no no no no
we can do it in person and then on
instagram so what turns you off
okay the first thing when i check it me
i get into the instagram
that's the first thing okay i say how is
it
also i see if we have like a person that
we know we have like
mutual friends exactly and if i see
he's not gonna so i leave that message
there
and who knows in the future how many
instagram messages do you get
a day from people you don't know oh i
don't know
there's the number for you right there
she gave us a number
[Laughter]
yeah that's the european like that's too
many to count i think it's officially
so just too many you don't even look
through all of them right yeah sometimes
i look if i have important message or
something but only at the important
messages
yeah yeah you don't go through all of
them and read all no yeah
i don't know if he has a blue check on
instagram right no if he has a blue
check you'll respond
come on that one they are like on the
principle you know you have
two yeah the general the general in the
main inbox exactly
but if a blue check messages you you're
opening it not all of them i can show
you
ladies and gentlemen easy mode is having
a pair of tits yeah man i wish i had
some titties man
it's not oh my gosh everyone always
thinks they'd be in like the top ten
percent of women
but like if you had boobs and you're
ugly
it's not yeah what about in person
and the one thing they don't tell you
about being a girl is you're
like valued so much more in your looks
than men and it's just like
i feel like guys don't have to deal with
that because they're never
like that's not what's important not in
like
the dating marketplace and like just the
way society i guess views you
in person like if you met a guy face to
face what will turn you off
depends like depends
um maybe like it's there's something
that always turns you off like if any
guy does
something you're done like if he talks
too much if he's like yeah
that's one of the things when someone
talk too much i mean i'm like
can you let me just talk it's like
he's telling me how all his life i'm
just like
uh-huh yes okay
okay guys let me know in the comments
what you agree with and what you
disagree with don't forget to subscribe